yeah hello and welcome to this video you
click again I want to see playing if you
change weight and spoon for the main
line with f6e yeah just try this out I'm
not a real expert in know how this is
precisely play but I know the the
general ideas from from my black
experience black side experience though
I never played f6 though always felt
that this is a bit I know didn't like it
check check put it short always found it
a little bit a little bit boring for
black but it is extremely solid know
maybe it's playing the 936 m YT m is
aiming for me aiming for endings of
course where his better pawn structure
Celts in some way black hair fields a
little bit a little bit off I've got
four against three which is the main
thing so I should be comfortable in an
ending the best ending here would be the
king and porn ending of course this is
what like definitely will avoid okay I
want to do want to be precise if i go
here
should be five be 350 for my book cannot
be trapped here right no want to make
sure there's nothing funky going on okay
so be five yeah that that might be
something that he wants to try okay I
wonder if a four is a movie or not or if
I just want you want to keep this keep
this tension it's maybe not so bad that
be five Roxy one this del threaten to
take almost I thought taking Bishop
things but okay I have to go here first
King on d3 is not been anyway so what
I'm trying to say is sometimes I have a
takes its not reacting to it maybe it is
no threat I thought taking yeah pawn
takes Bishop takes d5 Bishop legs before
okay a drupe take c5 check King b6 ride
upon up in this ending not sure though
how much it is actually before we can
take things look située will he will get
active with this rook to a3 okay I can I
can keep this option and see what he
does this is comfortable anyway and the
same thing is possible again slightly
better circumstances
I mean you cannot do anything anyway
[Music]
least that's what I thought I feel ok
now go into the rook ending on do I have
something better I can do this first
that is also if you know + f5 I'm
definitely going for this ok check now
f5 is there to pick up to be picked up
[Music]
you can play rookie 85 you to cover this
but I have aged 54 a very very outside
person well it looks bad the only thing
that's not good is if it checks me ok I
can go to d3 yeah
and it seems he has not anticipated that
idea at all I mean I was playing for
this the whole time just try to improve
the position before before I strike okay
so what's going on here the simplest
thing would be Roxy 7 try to pick up the
H porn that should be pretty strong
right if I pick up the H porn and yeah
that's very strong so just f4 or ticket
if I take it I'm coming up all the way
to age 7 so that must be good
and have a FOIA for a pawn so that looks
like an end and game when iam
[Music]
[Music]
so that's that's really thing about it
yet h7 record it for me yeah that must
be enough so what you say for me Utley
can also go away for me a limb that
should be quicker
[Music]
a & age phone is a little bit too much I
hope his King is cut off by my Roku time
morning just want to prevent him from
pushing me pushing me back to the to the
to the to the back rank it's a black
resigned yeah okay now that was a good
ending I think somewhere in the opening
I think he lost one or two Tempe and
then already got got somewhat awkward I
don't I don't know the exact move Sam
don't really don't really do that yeah
this is this is looking very normal I
think white normally plays a to e three
but well this cannot be terribly bad
check check so I mean somewhere around
here something must have gone wrong
somewhere here the engine is killing me
only a minimum edge which should be fair
i don't think i should have anything
here but somehow that wasn't easy all of
a sudden see for us given by the
computer i know here he already has to
be a little bit on the lookout hear
something more like this channel work
and he has no i mean what he did is
basically yeah admission of failure some
way after after the capture white is
better I mean in some way yeah this
looks okay right why not yeah put
something on light squares maybe King up
later
the problem here was also that he never
played c4 he allowed me to place your
form and now this is a bit awkward you
cannot go up to eight yeah this is this
ending is also torturous so yeah now we
have this situation where I'm just able
to improve slightly yeah now here
already had this option had to take take
take but it's a check so I went him and
now check it was possible but I didn't
feel this is so clear who ate you
checking here and then he's coming in
here I wasn't completely sure it felt
like I haven't you go back and I wasn't
sure that I'm really doing all that much
in this position when the engine likes
my position okay I can't do that that's
true and age form but i don't know i can
get to f4 right well it's good for what
hmm i didn't see the activity correctly
so what I decided was to just improve a
little bit more intense even now no I
felt the time is right to check yeah and
he cannot I mean he can do it jesam and
then something like protect us but check
problem is that this is a complete loss
I'm promoting here and we cannot do that
then we have the this lost ending f4 is
also winning but this is pretty clean
because I get the ape on going and I can
probably play five immediately or a six
foot ok I played it in a very safe way
it doesn't really matter a porn is too
strong again you can check
once and then then it's the end to two
pawns in too much yeah nice and give win
thanks for watching